I am six degrees of Kevin Bacon away
from our next two presenters look it up
on the Internet
please welcome Scarlett Johansson and
Matthew McConaughey
continuing our theme of sound and vision
Scarlett and I have the pleasure of
presenting the Academy Awards that honor
excellence in sound some of the nominees
for best sound mixing are about to hear
something beautiful the sound of their
names being called to accept an Oscar
the sound sound the sound here the
nominees for achievement in sound mixing
inception Laura Hirschberg Gary a Rizzo
and Ed Novick the King's Speech
Paul Hamlin Martin Jenson and John
Midgley salt
Jeffrey J huh Boosh Greg P Russell Scott
Milan and Williams Hiroki the social
network Ren Kleiss David Parker Michael
semanek and marked Weingarten True Grit
skip Lev say Craig Berkey Greg Orla and
Peter F curling and the Oscar goes to
Laura Laura Irish burg area and
Oh Fred oh my gosh this is this is
unbelievable thank you thank you to all
the Academy voters thank you to our
family and our wonderful wives Susan
Laura and Jennifer we need to thank
everybody at Warner Brothers
post-production and we need to thank all
the hard-working boom operators and
utilities sound people that worked on
the production crew union of course we
need to you know we really mmm
we share this award with Lee Smith with
Richard King with Michael Babcock with
Alex Gibson Alan Meyerson Hans Zimmer
and of course the mighty Christopher
Nolan Chris is the architect with the
soundtrack in every way he is the
creative force behind every decision
that we made and so this is as much win
for him as it is for us so
congratulations Chris and thank you very
much